Hallo meine Süßen!
Heute gibt es ein Dessert und zwar eines, das nicht gebacken werden muss,
also ein No Bake Dessert.
Und ich habe gedacht dadurch, dass es jetzt eben so warm ist, verzichte ich auch noch zusätzlich auf Sahne.
Und das Rezept geht auch wirklich sehr schnell und ist total Anfänger-geeignet.
Ich fange jetzt auch direkt an, ich fange jetzt mit der Creme an.
Hier habe ich Mascarpone und diesmal nehme ich Schmandt,
ihr könntet Schmandt auch durch Creme fraiche ersetzen
aber ich schreibe euch sowieso alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben hier unten in die Videobeschreibung.
Jetzt verrühre ich das und ihr braucht außerdem auch keine Küchenmaschine,
also in diesem Rezept braucht ihr wirklich sehr wenig!
So, jetzt gebe ich das da rein und verrühre das einfach mit dem Schneebesen.
So, Mascarpone und Schmandt habe ich auch nur kurz miteinander verrührt,
wichtig ist eben dass, ihr nicht zu viel und zu lange rührt damit sich die Flüssigkeit nicht trennt.
Jetzt gebe ich da noch die folgenden 4 Zutaten dazu: einmal Puderzucker für die Süße,
Sahnefest, das bindet auch nochmal so ein bisschen,
dann für den Geschmack Vanilleextrakt und außerdem Haselnuss-Brotaufstrich.
Und das verrühren wir dann auch nur ganz kurz miteinander.
Und die Creme ist fertig, wir machen auch direkt weiter.
Ich habe hier meinen Backrahmen und den habe ich auf einen Tortenretter gestellt,
einfach damit ich 'ne Unterlage habe.
Und jetzt beginnen wir zu schichten. Ich nehme jetzt als Boden die Loacker Neapolitaner.
Ich habe euch Loacker schon mal vorgestellt in einem Video, das verlinke ich euch auch gerne.
Loacker, das ist ein Familienunternehmen aus Südtirol. Finde ich persönlich sehr cool
und supporte ich sehr gerne. Und was ich auch super wichtig finde: die benutzen eben kein Vanillin,
kein künstliches Vanillin sondern nur echte Bourbon Vanille.
So und da öffne ich mir jetzt einfach mal ein paar Packungen und schichte den Boden damit
und dann kommt die komplette Creme darüber.
So, jetzt habe ich alles glatt verstrichen und wenn ihr euren Backrahmen auf 21 x 24 cm einstellt,
dann passt es perfekt mit den Neapolitanern.
Und die restlichen werde ich jetzt in Quadrate schneiden
oder so ein bisschen klein schneiden für die Deko später.
Und natürlich auch zwischendurch ein bisschen naschen, wir müssen uns ja auch stärken!
Und dann zeige ich euch die Glasur. Jaa?
(H: Alleine essen macht dick!)
Das stimmt, deswegen teile ich jetzt mit dir!
(H: Danke!)
Bitte!
Für die Schokoladenglasur jetzt ganz einfach Vollmilchkuvertüre zusammen mit Butter
über einem Wasserbad erhitzen und schmelzen lassen und das gebt ihr dann über die Mascarpone-Creme.
Jetzt müssen wir das Ganze nur noch kühlen und je länger ihr kühlt,
desto fester wird die Mascarpone-Creme. ich denke mal 2h sollten ausreichen.
Falls ihr das Ganze am Vortag vorbereiten möchtet, dann könnt ihr das sehr gerne tun
und lasst es einfach über Nacht im Kühlschrank.
So und danach lösen wir ganz einfach noch den Backrahmen mit dem Backformlöser
und dekorieren nach Herzens...lust?
Genau, nach Herzenslust! Natürlich passen Neapolitaner am besten oder auch Haselnüsse
oder aber frische Früchte, passend zur Saison passt auch immer wunderbar.
Und uns schmeckt das Ganze sehr sehr gut weil eben Mascarpone und Schmandt so eine frische Kombi ist!
Und ja, ansonsten wünsche ich euch jetzt ganz viel Freude beim Nachmachen!
Backen müsst ihr ja nicht, schreibt mir gerne weitere Rezeptwünsche
hier unten in die Kommentare. Abonniert den Kanal komplett kostenlos
damit ihr nichts mehr verpasst und dann sehen wir uns auch bei meinem nächsten Rezept.
Tschüss, eure Kiki!